So if we look at the parallel operating system
and page fault service the easy scenario for the
parallel operating system is what I call as a
multiprocess workload. And here what we're seeing is, yes you
have threads executing on all the nodes of the
multiprocessor, but these threads are completely independent of one
another. Think of this as a separate process, this
as an independent process. Maybe you have a web browser
here, a word processor here, and so on. So they
are completely independent processes. And if that is the case,
if there's a page fault that has incurred on, on
this node, simultaneously a page fault on another node, they can
be handled completely independently. Why? Because the threads are independent.
The page tables are distinct. And therefore, you don't have
to serialize the page fault service, as I told you,
the parallel operating system is going to have a page fault handler
that's available in each one of these nodes. So the
work can be done in parallel, so long as there is
no data structures that are shared among these different units of
work that the operating system has to do. And so long
as page tables are distinct, which is the case in
a multi-process workload, there is no stabilization. And life will be
good. The hard scenario for a parallel operating system is a
multi-threaded workload. Now what I mean by a multi-threaded workload is
that you have a process that as multiple threads,
so there is opportunity for exploiting the concurrency that's available
in the multiprocessor by scheduling these threads on the
different nodes of the multiprocessor. And to make it concrete,
what I'm going to show you is two notes,
N1 and N2, and let's assume that there are two
cores available in each one of these nodes. In that
case, what I can do is, the operating system may
have chosen to put T1 and T3 on node N1, and T2 and T4 on node
N2. So you have a multithreaded workload now
executing on different nodes of the multiprocessor. And there
is hardware concurrency, because there are multiple cores
available. So in principle, all of these threads
can work in parallel, and if they incur a page fault it is in incumbent on the
operating system to see how it can ensure
that there is no serialization of the work that
needs to be done to service the page faults.
So if we want to naiively think about what the
parallel operating system would be doing in this scenario,
the address space is shared and therefore, the page
table is shared. And since the threads are executing
on different processors, The TLBs will have shared entries,
in the process of TLBs, because they are accessing
the same address space. So that'll be the scenario. Now
if you think about it, what we would want
is to limit the amount of sharing in the operating
system data structures when they are executing on different
processors. In particular, for this particular mapping that I've shown
you, that T1 and T3 are executing on N1 and
T2 and T4 are executing on, on N2, what we
would want is the operating system data structures, that they have to
mess with, T1 and T3 have to mess with, should be distinct
from the operating system data structures that T2 and T4 may have
to mess with. And that will ensure that you can have scalability.